in the background of the impeachment inquiry
in the background of trying to bribe Ukraine
in the background of Donald Trump's taxes.
In the background of Trump abandoning the
Kurds in Syria and the immediate bombings
carried out on Kurdish forces by Turkey.
There are 26 new sexual assault allegations
against Donald Trump.
There is a new book, all the presidents of
women, Donald Trump and the making of a predator.
The book was written by Barry Levine and Monique
L Phi E, Z where there are 43 new allegations
of inappropriate behavior with women by Donald
Trump.
Of those 43 26 rise to what we would realistically
call unwanted sexual contact or sexual assault,
as many of us refer to it, the theme is always
the same.
Trump is using Trump's throwing his wealth
around.
Trump's throwing his power around and sometimes
he's throwing his weight around in a literal
sense.
The fact that he is physically a large guy,
uh, to sexually assault women, to touch them
in bathrooms, everything that you can imagine.
One example has Donald Trump allegedly hiding
behind a tapestry to grope a woman at his
Mar-a-Lago estate.
There are literally dozens of examples.
I'm not going to go through all of them here.
The book even identifies the women that Melania
Trump viewed at the time as the biggest threats
to her status as Donald Trump's primary girlfriend.
Melania, of course, now Trump's wife and the
first lady, uh, during a brief breakup between
Donald Trump and Melania over trust issues.
Trump report reportedly really scaled up the
sexual assaults on women.
And, uh, I think this is an important point
at which I should mention there are people
who are talking about the infidelity component
of Donald Trump and Melania Trump's relationship.
I don't care about that.
I truly could not care less about that.
I don't care if bill Clinton cheats on Hillary.
I don't care if Trump tweets on Melania, which
obviously he does.
I mean these paid off mistresses during his
marriage.
That's not really the important part.
They can do whatever they want in their relationship,
whatever relationship works for them, good
for them.
The important parts are, we've got a predator
here who is sexually assaulting women.
This is someone who is possibly illegally
paying off the women.
And these are women whose stories are often
suppressed by everything from physical threats
to hush money.
Remember that in the case of stormy Daniels,
she alleges that her, uh, I believe it's daughter,
uh, was threatened implicitly by a guy in
a parking lot who came up to her saying, you
don't want to talk about this Trump stuff.
And there has been no accountability.
In part, there has been no accountability
because the Trump electorate, even evangelicals
who claim to vote their values, they would
rather vote for a serial sex assaulter than
for a Democrat period.
I mean that, that's, it's a simple as that
with millions of Republican voters.
And in the end, uh, the big picture is these
are people who claim that they are all about
their values, but then they don't actually
live them.
They don't actually vote them.
Certainly.
Uh, and it's important to remember, you know,
Trump's previously said, when you're famous
or rich or whatever, they just let you do
it.
Apparently not.
Uh, just when we think that we are starting
to kind of wrap our heads around how disgusting
he is, we learn of about 26 new allegations
in this case.
And meanwhile, I mean, this is, it gives me
the chills.
Mike Pence, his wife Karen Pence, said, I
believe it was at a rally last night or the
night before and minute in Minnesota that
she loves how Donald Trump treats young women.
Can you imagine being either this disconnected
from reality, uh, or this, uh, malignantly
a dishonest to go onto a stage and say about
a guy who has talked about how if Ivanka weren't
his daughter.
Dot.
Who has, uh, treated so many women terribly
who has admitted to just going up and grabbing
whatever it is that he grabs for her to say
he loves, she loves how he treats young women.
Now I do think it would be good to prevent
this story from going away again because it
gets buried.
And when you have, you know, the 18th the
19th the 20th I mean we've got it's 16 or
17 allegations.
We had, this is 26 more.
We're talking about around 45 women that are
two different degrees accusing Donald Trump
of sexual assault.
I get that he's not going to face legal consequences.
The statute of limitations has elapsed on
many of these, but it feels like the least
we can do is keep this in the news.
Don't let it get buried so that it's in addition
to trying to extort Ukraine and this story
and that political scandal and not cooperating
with impeachment and all of this other stuff.
In addition to all of that stuff, we can keep
the fact that there's no way all of these
women are making this up in the news, that
there is one way to hold Donald Trump accountable
no matter what the statute of limitations
is on sexual assault and that's by voting
him out of office in November of 2020 I believe
there would be a benefit to keeping this in
the news.
Although Trump via political scandal has done
a really good job of making the sexual assault
stories go away, uh, and the media, you know,
they'll, when a story is hot, they will try
to pull in.
Uh, one of the accusers, for example, E Jean
Carol was one that Anderson Cooper interviewed,
interviewed didn't go particularly well, but
once that initial ratings hit goes away, the
stories tend to go away as well.
And I think that this is definitely something
that should be kept in the news.
Let's take a quick break.
Make sure you're following the David [inaudible]
when show on Instagram at David Pakman show
while you were there.
Follow me on
instagram@daviddotpacmanaswellthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com.